are your video games just not swifty  enough here's the good news Adult Swim  favorite Rick and Morty is coming to  mobile devices from a brief clip Adult  Swim tweet it out the game seems to play  very similar to handheld Pokemon titles  we don't know if it's headed I OS  Android or both but Chris Johnson of  Adult Swim games has confirmed it'll be  free when it releases on january  fourteenth we'll have to wait until then  to see what sort of interdimensional  trouble the boys get into this isn't the  first time Rick and Morty have appeared  in a video game the boys are also  available as it dota 2 announcer pack  and that's probably not the last we'll  see of them when we hear more about  adult swim's space-traveling duo you'll  hear more about it on gamespot